avec la coved 19 en ce moment on se pose
cette question est ce que l'avenir des
entreprises en biotechnologie est en jeu
ce sont des entreprises qui se sentent
oubliés en ce moment par les programmes
de soutien des gouvernements
annie perreault et directrice général de
bioquébec bonsoir madame perron bonsoir
monsieur fillon alors bioquébec d'abord
parlez nous de ce que c'est qu'ils
représentent et vous exactement
alors bien au québec c'est le réseau
québécois des entreprises en
biotechnologie est à dire les
entreprises qui développent des
médicaments des thérapies des tests
diagnostiques des vaccins nous habiller
au québec on représente plus de 125 de
ces entreprises qui sont à travers le
québec
jamais dans lequel on les connaît bien
comme un medicago par exemple qu'au real
is pharma opt-in à il y en a plusieurs
ah oui donc vous êtes vous est plus
qu'important là c'est en ces temps de
crise
pourquoi les programmes actuels ne vous
touche pas ne couvre pas vos activités
notamment la subvention salariale que ce
qui se passe
la plupart des programmes qui ont été
annoncées dont ce programme important de
la subvention salariale qui ont des
critères d'éligibilité qui entre autres
inclut les revenus les entreprises en
biotechnologie n'ont pas de revenus la
plupart bras très long devant tel 6 7 8
10 ans de développement et de recherche
pour mettre au point ces thérapies ces
médicaments dont je vous ai parlé
donc elles sont au niveau des dépenses
l'impact pour elle de ce qui se passe
actuellement ce n'est pas sur les
revenus mais sur leur capacité à aller
se financer sur les marchés financiers
mais vous avez des subventions je
présume oui et certaines entreprises
reçoivent définir des subventions vous
avez raison mais la plupart dans la
presle sont financés à travers par
exemple les capitaux de risque et déjà
il ya des gardes et comme vous le savez
ces capitaux jusque là son finance les
entreprises en biotechnologie sur la
base des deux objectifs scientifiques à
réaliser plusieurs des entreprises
actuellement ont dû suspendre leurs
projets de recherche donc ces objectifs
là ne pourront pas être réalisés et le
financement vont être de plus en plus
en plus les marchés financiers vous le
savez sa peau était facile dans les
dernières semaines ya plusieurs grands
fonds qui font qu'ils doivent se
rétablir rééquilibrer leurs
portefeuilles
et ça ça signifie moins de sous
disponible pour relier les marchés
risqués qui sont ceux par exemple de la
biotechnologie et donc est ce qu'il ya
déjà des entreprises en ce moment de
biotechnologie qui ont dû arrêter leur
activité arrêter leurs travaux de
recherche
bien sûr il ya évidemment plein
d'entreprises en biotech qui travaille
sur la colline du mécano d'autres qui
travaillent sur des champs
thérapeutiques tout aussi important
l'oncologie la neurologie les maladies
cardiaques et certaines d'entre elles
ont dû arrêter je pense entre autre hier
j'ai eu une conversation avec la
présidente d'opt-in à à montréal qui
travaille sur la maladie d'alzheimer et
la fin des remboursements aux crédits
d'impôt à la recherche
elle a dû arrêter ses projets de
recherche son financement avec le
capital de risque a énormément diminué
déjà ils ont reçu des indications qu'ils
ne recevraient que la moitié qu'est ce
qui était espéré
elle a dû mettre à pied certains
employés donc on vient toucher
évidemment la capacité de ces
entreprises là de reprendre lorsque la
crise vont être terminées ça va à
l'encontre un peu de ce que le
gouvernement souhaite on souhaite garder
les employés
ici on parle d'employés de haute qualité
et on veut que l'équipe reste mobilisée
pour qu'après la crise on puisse
reprendre les programmes de recherche là
où il était vous n'avez pas les
entreprises axées la subvention
salariale gelé bien compris mais en même
temps il ya des prêts des prêts jusqu'à
40000 ottawa aujourd'hui québec annoncé
des prêts disponibles pour des petites
entreprises jusqu'à 50000 investissement
québec également des prêts pour plus de
50 mille dollars de prêts ou de
garanties prêts est-ce que ça ça
pourrait être utile pour les entreprises
de biotechnologies effectivement
certaines de nos entreprises qui sont
plus petit pourrait peut-être avoir
accès à ces programmes sont tout
nouveaux on en a entendu parler entre
autres d'un aujourd'hui n'est encore les
détails mais on a transmis les
informations à nos membres nous ce que
l'on souhaite c'est que le gouvernement
révise ses critères d'éligibilité pour
qu'ils puissent inclure par exemple les
bio technologies on regarde heure là
salariale nos entreprises sont prêtes à
s'engager à garder la masse salariale
tels que les sinon la rendre supérieur à
la même période dans les prochains mois
et on souhaite que ainsi en modifiant
les critères d'éligibilité nos
entreprises pourront avoir accès aux
programmes les plus importants peut-être
qu'effectivement les programmes qui ont
été annoncées qui touche les plus
petites entreprises vont également avoir
un impact sur certaines de nos
bibliothèques mais pour l'instant ce qui
sera important c'est qu'on reconnaisse
le caractère distinctif des
bibliothèques
on est dans une crise sanitaire ça
serait un petit peu ironique si les
entreprises qui dans le monde
travaillent à aider à mettre un frein à
cette pandémie puis aussi à faire des
recherches sur d'autres chantent et
parapublic soit les plus affectées mais
finalement par les mesures qui sont
prises
est-ce que vous avez l'oreille de
pierrefeu tribune ministre de l'économie
un ancien du secteur des biotechs qu'il
était chez atrium autrefois autrefois
vous avez tout à fait raison et on a une
excellente relation avec le gouvernement
du québec
personnellement je suis en lien avec le
bureau de monsieur fait du guémon
presque quotidiennement
on sent que qu'ils comprennent bien ce
que nous demandons disons que le
programme qui touche actuellement la
plus grande partie de nos entreprises
c'est un programme fédéral alors on a
demandé le soutien de monsieur fait du
début pour nous appuyer auprès du
gouvernement fédéral
ces changements alors et lieux mais pour
l'instant je peux vous dire qu'on semble
avoir les coteaux du bureau de monsieur
fils du guide
alors bonne chance madame perron merci
beaucoup merci merci à vous monsieur
fillion